hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i am
just so excited to get to tell you guys
my new job after leaving rooster teeth
fun house and inside gaming
three weeks ago maybe i think it has
been
very fun to watch people guess what i
would be doing next and i do want to say
i only saw two people guess correctly
literally
two one person here on youtube and one
person on twitter
everyone else was pretty far off base a
lot of people thinking i was doing
community management or pr or marketing
which
meh that ain't me so let me just tell
you and try not to get emotional about
it because i feel like i've already had
too many sentimental moments on youtube
over the past year
but it is also a very big deal to me
that i get to announce this today
because
i feel like i've been working towards
this
i mean it's even better than what i was
working towards but for the last five
years this has been the direction that
i've been heading in and i've been
putting
kind of everything into
being in this let's just do it
[Laughter]
hi i'm alana and i'm a video game writer
at sony santa monica who you might know
as the studio who make
god of war i am writing a video game
at one of my favorite studios in the
entire world
who made one of the one of my favorites
clearly subjective and like kind of
extra weird now because now i think i
have to give you guys disclosures all
the time
hello i am technically a sony employee
before i say this full disclosure
i think that god of war is one of the
best games of the generation they sent
me
this nice thermos
[Laughter]
and i have this dual shock 4
i i love it i love it so much this is
this is a huge deal for me um any of you
who know me well know how much i love
god of war
and anyone who's probably even seen less
of my content knows that
my next step in life the next thing i've
repeatedly said that i wanted to do was
be a video game writer
my two passions my entire life have
always been video games and writing
which is why i've never considered
myself a host or a presenter
um i've always been a writer producer
first and foremost
and uh have very little interest in
working on camera which is a plus of
this job is that i don't have to do it
anymore
i just get to write and you know when i
left funhouse i said it was just an
opportunity that i couldn't pass up and
to be completely explicit what i meant
by that was
it was my goal to write a video game
that is what i wanted to do that is what
i've been working towards for a long
time now by writing screenplays
i wrote 10 short stories this year
writing books um i've consulted on three
video games and technically worked on
two
all of that stuff is just in the back
end it's not stuff that i really talk
about publicly but it is all stuff that
i was making effort to do i contributed
to a game jam i spoke to three studios
about just going to sit in their writers
room so that i know how video games are
written so it's basically like a skill
set that i've been trying
very hard to cultivate to make sure that
i have experience
but what i expected was that i would
have to start out
um working for an indie studio working
for a smaller studio who may not have
properties that i'm super passionate
about
and the reality is junior positions
so rarely show up in aaa development um
which is where i want to be working i
want to be working for
sony santa monica like genuinely i i
i'm in such disbelief um and then when
this position came about and i was
contacted about it
and it turned out that there was a
junior position
at a triple a studio for this exact
thing that i wanted to do
um again that's what i mean when i said
i i there's no way that i couldn't leave
funhouse
this kind of position so rarely comes
around and um i've been working so hard
at making myself
equipped for it um still not even
expecting to be able to work in triple a
because yeah people who haven't already
shipped a triple-a game are so much less
likely to get hired
but this particular position is looking
for that so it's just
um the most incredible thing in the
world and i am
so so so happy i'm so passionate about
video game writing and um i love this
studio so much i have met a number of
people who work there and collaborated
with them in the past i hosted a panel
for them
a few years ago they are truly
incredible and i like at some point i
will get to say we
like i'm a part of santa monica studio
is just
it's just mind-blowing i guess there are
some things that i need to address for
my audience here
um play watch listen is not going
anywhere that is another thing about the
studio that's incredible is that they
were very
um willing to work with me on you know
the the person that i am and the stuff
that i
am known for doing and um making it an
easy
transition where obviously i am by no
means games media anymore
under zero circumstances i work in video
game development now that is a step that
we have taken
across the board it may annoy you guys
that i'm going to for legal reasons
because i don't want to screw this up
any time that i have to disclose that
i'm a sony employee i'm going to have to
do that probably pretty frequently
but i might just overdo it and maybe we
make a meme out of it just because i
want to be careful with
ftc guidelines but my point there was
play watch listen is staying which is my
games industry podcast for anyone who
doesn't know
that doesn't go anywhere i'm still
allowed to do streams i'm still allowed
to do let's plays gameplay videos all
that stuff
um i will have less spare time now so
i'm not going to promise the same
frequency that i've had over the last
few months or at least since june is
when i started uploading a lot more
before that it was like once or twice a
week so it'll probably drop back
but i'm still allowed to make stuff i
guess related um a much less important
side note really but uh a lot of people
did highlight this
in some cases sort of aggressively uh
the reason that i was not given a
playstation 5 was not because i like
game pass
it's because it was considered an
ethical um conflict in the end
that you can't have me talking about
playstation 5 while also
being an employee under contract just
having no one know that publicly yet so
um i am in full agreement with them on
that it is a bummer that i couldn't get
one to the inside gaming team
um as a result of that people seem to be
very confused about that
so i just wanted to address it to erase
those questions that is why that
happened
and i guess the only thing that i need
from you guys is uh
i will not be talking about what i'm
working on i'm not going to talk about
anything that i'm doing i'm not going to
talk about what my days are like
that is a barrier that now becomes
completely private a because i work in
triple a game development and b because
i kind of want it to be
my job has had to be public for so long
where the stuff that i make is literally
in front of
people's faces the next day or a week
later
um so my plan right now is to basically
just lock off that part of my life and
not have it be public
um i'm sure if there are tremendous
things that i want to share then i will
but for the most part i think that
i will just say i'm not going to be
talking about what i do for a living
ultimately it'll be
hi i am a writer santa monica studio
but yeah i can't give you literally any
more information than that and uh don't
intend to ultimately so that is a thing
that i know is going to be
a bit of an adjustment because i'm so
transparent all the time but that is
always going to be the answer
uh if i'm asked in a stream about what
i'm doing or what i wrote in that day
i'm not going to answer that stuff i
don't mind telling you guys that i'm
enjoying my job
but i am definitely going to approach
this with maximum professionalism and
hope that my audience can respect that
too because
if it gets to a point where i have to
like mute the phrase god of war from my
chats or something that would be
a pretty big bummer so hopefully uh we
don't get to that point and you guys can
understand the position i'm in and i
will
still continue to make content um that
is definitely a thing that i
intended to do very much but for the
most part aside from the increase in
disclosures
i don't think things will change that
much for my audience ultimately other
than um
[Music]
i just i'm just so happy like i'm just
so
stoked to be working on something that
is a longer form product
and be very collaborative with a lot of
people uh santa monica studio is a big
studio
it is a world-class studio and um
i love all of that stuff and it really
aligns with who i am as a person
is learning from smart people and and
learning how to write a video game
uh again i did make sure that i've i've
gotten some experience over the last
five years but this is
this is a whole other ball game of
course and of course they know that for
me too
so yes i'm alana full disclosure i'm a
sony employee i'm just gonna start it
now
i will see you guys next time bye